it doesn't really matter how much money
you make or how much money you have
that's really the thing because I'm not
asking you for a large financial
contribution if it costs $20 to sub $20
is quite a bit of money $20 is quite a
bit quite a bit is she from Canada
probably she has given the paleness I'm
gonna say yes you can get a full meal
for $20 and the difference of $20 and I
love how this starts honestly like a
motivational speech I'm gonna let I know
right I'm just gonna let this play yeah
let's run it back just to get the full
statement but people are hard sitting
here thinking right now like okay this
is gonna help me write the next few
minutes are gonna be insightful for me
and I'm gonna take something away from
this video right yeah how're you think
it's right $20 is you can get a full
meal for $20 and the difference of $20
and eating a meal is in that $20 like
that's where it is but a sub is $4 at
maxim's what did she say the difference
between eating of me yeah
[Laughter]
it's with the classic [ __ ] or
economics she just she said it so like
sure idli yeah that's like some pyramid
scheme [ __ ] right there no cuz you put
the money in and then it goes in and
then it comes back out and the
difference is sitting in between right
right
imagine you're eating a meal at Tim
Hortons right $20 $20 can quite a bit of
money
yeah I can buy you for full meals at Tim
Hortons imagine you didn't eat one of
those meals so you're sitting into more
than with three meals okay
that meal that you're not eating that's
where the money that's where the
difference lies okay huh
yeah I'm stuff I don't even need to get
her original statement what the [ __ ] was
that although I'm gonna listen really
closely because we all know math is hard
for me $20 like that's where it is and
the difference of $20 and eating a meal
is in that $20 like that's where it is
what does it mean tell me I think what
she's saying is the difference between
$20 and eating a meal is that's it right
there it's it's $20 it's in the $20
right there but what but that's the
weirdest backwards way of saying $20 can
buy you a meal that's so funny that was
the weirdest way of saying yeah $20 is
$20 the difference between not eating a
meal and eating a meal is having the $20
that's the difference
welcome to economics with Jay Alvarez
all right welcome to how currency works
yeah a sub is $5 at maximum in whatever
your currency is it's maybe ten dollars
and it doesn't matter how broke you are
if you have time to watch twitch you
have you have ten dollars truly if you
that's an hey bet there's another little
macroeconomic ya down there Twitter
users a watched which equals ten dollars
in the wallet
yeah guaranteed every time mm-hmm every
time every [ __ ] time
yeah don't if you watch twitch you have
ten dollars
you definitely have ten dollars no and I
love how she follows it up watch ten
dollars truly if you don't have ten
dollars you probably don't have time to
watch twitch because you should be
working
you should be trying to earn money it's
not a ton it's not like a ton of money
oh my god I hate this dig oh man Oh like
okay first of all white go ahead I was
going to say should we just let her
finish before we go in sure yeah sure
sure sure
actually maybe cuz we're done we're
gonna forget everything we're gonna say
so go ahead I was just gonna say twitch
is free that's yes it's ad-supported
right yes sums and everything is an
extra layer that's the user that's the
audience's choice yes
if you stream on Twitch you're agreeing
that you're doing it for free free at
least I mean they give you a cut of the
ad revenue as as YouTube but that's not
a guarantee you can make zero money you
could make whatever but if you're doing
it for free the hope is you make money
from people contributing the water you
channel develop some a show or segments
that are entertaining and people see the
value in your strengths did you see X
[ __ ] this dude xqc I was crying he
like responded this clip it's it's like
he's like first of all xq cease voice
and speech cadence is so funny I'm not
gonna try to copy it because it's so
he's like Swedish something isn't yeah
but he's like it someone asked him about
this he says zero brain opinion man 0 IQ
opinion man zero just like stars all
really calm he just starts building up
into yelling by the end of it you stream
[ __ ] sucks
subscribe to it cuz your stream [ __ ]
sucks makeup better straight in the clip
just cuts off right there it's true man
what do you think all this [ __ ]
freshman college girl dorm decorations
are the lights in the back and [ __ ] like
that you know maybe you should shame
them into it maybe that yeah I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna shade her set just
yet but why
I'm gonna hold off on oh wait till we
get all the way through it okay also the
thing I really wanted to say it was
oh you don't you don't like that you
don't get paid talked to every [ __ ]
creative person ever
every standup every artist every one has
ever tried to entertain people talk to
them for the first five [ __ ] years of
their career [ __ ] money they made
goddamn talk to the people that are
sitting in coffee beans in the [ __ ]
valley yeah
writing writing day after day writing
yeah for free all you got to do is sit
in front of a [ __ ] camera
I'm not saying streaming is easy by any
means I'm not saying that at all but but
there's a difference between having to
sit and and I don't know at least write
[ __ ] down on a page
bro for free the I think I mean like the
barrier to entry
you've already bridged it you have good
internet you definitely have a great
computer right you have all the gear to
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] and you you have
what a lot of people wish they had and
you pull up just sitting on accounts
being like give me your money do
something come on man come on
anyway so being like I'm broke I can't
afford to sub it that doesn't really
track what you mean to say I'm so
condescending I hate it dude that
doesn't really track those hands those
like Italian hands that she's doing
right now that is that is oh oh
someone's doing that [ __ ] to you and
just talking down at you with the
Italian hands [ __ ] off saying that
doesn't that doesn't track that there's
really a practice a that doesn't add up
oh I just reminds me of everybody like
really track what are you saying
it's like every middle manager at a
start-up [ __ ] mid 30s middle manager
who can't keep a boyfriend because she's
[ __ ] crazy doesn't really track Cody
you need to tuck in your shirt
okay you being overweight doesn't really
track okay cuz you get your belt or you
get your belt around your waist and
there's probably room for a shirt so it
has to go in your pants okay oh my god I
can't support the entertain oh god let's
let's let's hear this let's get this is
the this is a hook line sinker right
here money
I can't looking or to sub it that
doesn't really track what you mean to
say is I'm so irresponsible with my
money I can't support the entertainment
that I oh enjoy what you mean to say is
I'm so irresponsible with my money I
can't support the entertainment that I
oh enjoy oh my god she really thought
she really thought she hit him with the
whammy right there
yeah it's simple it's a simple it's
simple economics people yeah it's simple
alright twitch equals you have $10 if
you don't give to me so what's her name
invader v invader V minus $10 equals no
entertainment for you fine fine I'll
just go to the other [ __ ] million
good job don't shame me I know putting
money into this mo n what about the my
[ __ ]
what about this not being entertainment
well how about that yeah I'm not a nerd
I mean I am pretty entertained right now
actually this is entertainment
I would I would sub to her just to just
to make sure she keeps shame
her viewers so we can keep making fun of
her yeah this is like this is just like
the fin Dom [ __ ] the financial
domination stuff you're a broke little
[ __ ] yes I am yes I am yeah give me
your money you're a bad little boy
aren't you I am I'm a bad boy I love
your chav you don't even have twenty
dollars for a meal I don't I don't
you're so right
but I want to give it to you I love the
chats Tonks after she said all that
another guy what are the sub benefits
just genuinely serious sell me hey
invader V I'm pretty close to investing
just wondering if you could walk me
through the benefits wait wait I didn't
see the second half of this clip what's
the second half I'm unemployed basically
all my money goes to bills and food or I
would support you chicken yeah it's five
dollars it's really like you're never
you're not gonna you're no one's gonna
convince me that what I'm saying is so
rude or so unacceptable or so outrageous
it just simply isn't it's just it's five
dollars it doesn't I don't get it but
the argument works both ways if it's
just five bucks then don't beg for it
yeah both ways why do you [ __ ] eat it
so desperately why didn't like how do
you not see this contradiction it's
unfathomable to me that she doesn't
[ __ ] understand that she's doing the
same [ __ ] you're sitting there shaming
people for not giving you five dollars
it's just five bucks yeah yeah it's just
five dollars you're right it is just
five dollars damn dude
you